>> Kayleigh: THE RUSSIAN
OPPOSITION LEADER IS URGING THE
COUNTRY TO STAGE DAILY
PROTESTING AGAINST VITAMIN PUTIN
FOR HIS INVASION OF UKRAINE.
BACK AT HOME, PRESIDENT BIDEN
SHOULD A RALLY CRY STATE OF THE
UNION ADDRESS TO UNITE THE
NATION IN THE WORLD AGAINST
VLADIMIR PUTIN'S INVASION OF THE
UKRAINE.
HE VOWS TO MAKE RUSSIA'S LEADER
PAYING FOR UNLEASHING WAR IN
EUROPE.
>> WHEN REPORTING STARTED TO
SHAKE THE FOUNDATIONS OF THE
FREE WORLD, MAKING IT BEND,
ATTEMPTING TO, TO HIS MENACING
WAYS.
HE BADLY MISCALCULATED, THOUGHT
HE COULD ROLL ON THE UKRAINE,
AND THE WORLD WOULD ROLLOVER
INSTEAD, HE MET A WALL OF
STRENGTH HE NEVER IMAGINED.
HE MET THE UKRAINIAN PEOPLE.
>> Kayleigh: WHEN YOU THINK
ABOUT STATE OF THE UNIONS, I
THINK ABOUT LANDMARK MOMENTS
THAT WE ALL REMEMBER, JOHNSON
LAYING OUT THE WAR ON POVERTY,
THE AXIS OF EVIL COMMENTS BY
PRESIDENT BUSH, BILL CLINTON
PIVOTING -- I DON'T RECALL A
LINE LIKE THAT LAST NIGHT THAT
WILL MAKE THIS GO DOWN IN
HISTORY.
>> Bret: DEFINITELY NOT.
IT WAS A SPEECH -- THE
TRADITIONAL SHOPPING LIST OF A
PRESIDENT TRYING TO GET THINGS
DONE FROM A CONGRESS THAT IS
DIVIDED, AND NOT GETTING WHAT HE
WANTS DONE.
THE SPEECH WAS NOT INSPIRING,
WASN'T LOFTY.
THERE IS UNITY ON THE UKRAINE
ISSUE, AND YOU HAVE TO GIVE THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION CREDIT, FOR
REACHING OUT TO THE NATO
COUNTRIES FOR HAVING THAT SHEET
OF MUSIC.
THEIR CRITICS SAY THE HE'S
LEADING FROM BEHIND, LETTING THE
OTHER NATIONS LEAD THE WAY WITH
SANCTIONS.
HE'S STEERING AND TALKING AND
ENGAGING WITH THESE COUNTRIES.
ON THAT PART OF THE SPEECH AND
THE SANCTIONS, GOING DOWN THAT
ROAD, I THINK YOU'D HAVE
SUCCESS.
THE REST OF IT WAS LACKLUSTER.
YOU CAN'T POINT TO SOMETHING
THAT SAYS IT'S GOING TO CHANGE
THE DYNAMIC.
THEY HAD THE ABILITY TO SHIFT,
TO MAKE A DECISION, SHIFT
POLICY.
GO AFTER INDEPENDENCE, OVERCOME
ENERGY, DO SOMETHING THAT.
THERE WAS NO SWINGING.
THERE WAS NO FENCES.
THERE WAS NOTHING AS FAR AS
"BIG" IN THIS SPEECH.
>> Kayleigh: THAT'S A GREAT
DECISION.
HARRIS, ONE THING THAT STUCK OUT
TO BE, DUMB ECONOMIC INCOME OF
THAT WAS A KEY MOMENT WHERE WE
DID NOT HEAR PRESIDENT BIDEN --
I -- NO PRESIDENT DOES, BUT IN
MY VIEW, I WISH HE HAD GIVEN A
SLIGHT NOD TO THE 13TH --
>> Harris: I DON'T THINK IT'S
ALSO SO MUCH TO ASK THAT HE
COULD PUT THAT INTO MORE THAN AN
HOUR LONG SPEECH, IN TERMS OF
WHO YOU ARE IS THE PRESIDENT, AS
THE COMMANDER IN CHIEF.
I THINK YOU ARE RIGHT.
IF ANYBODY HAD DOUBT OF "MAYBE,
HE DIDN'T HAVE TIME," I WATCHED
LAST NIGHT.
I KNOW HE HAS A LOT OF CRISES
GOING ON, BUT HE MADE MORE
EMPHASIS PERHAPS -- ON HOW MUCH
HAS GONE WRONG WITH HIS
PRESIDENCY, AND HIT IT'S LIKE A
LAUNDRY LIST.
IT'S LIKE THE FOURTH OF JULY,
MUSIC IS OVER BUT THEY HAVE TO
LIGHT EVERYTHING.
[LAUGHTER]
YOU SEE ALL THE FIREWORKS ON
DISPLAY, BLUE, RED, GOLD, NONE
OF IT MAKES SENSE.
AFTER A WHILE, I THOUGHT WE ARE
"INDISCRIMINATELY GOING DOWN ON
THE PIER" STICK SET ON THE
POLES, ITEMS IN TERMS OF HIS
AGENDA.
"I'M GOING TO SECURE THE
BORDER."
I THOUGHT I HAD HALLUCINATED FOR
A MOMENT.
DIDN'T GO INTO HOW.
WE WERE TALKING ABOUT THIS LAST
HOUR, IS HE GOING TO DO IT WITH
THE WALL, WHAT WAS THE PLAN?
ALL OF IT WAS "TOUCH, BUT DON'T
GO DEEP."
GO TO UKRAINE, BUT DON'T GO SO
DEEP THAT YOU WOULD SAY THERE
WOULD BE A RED LINE.
MILITARIES OFF THE TABLE,
WHEN -- WANTS TO GO TO WAR, BUT
DON'T YOU SAY THAT ALL THINGS
ARE POSSIBLE IF, IF, IF?
WE DIDN'T GO DEEP LAST NIGHT.
>> Kayleigh: WOODEN.
JOSH GROBAN FROM THE WESTERN
POST POINTED OUT THAT THERE WERE
THINGS NOT MENTIONED IN -- SYRIA
WASN'T MENTIONED BECAUSE HE HAS
NO SYRIA STRATEGY AND THE TERMS
THAT TO THE CRIES OF SUFFERING
THERE.
ALMOST NO MENTION OF CHINA.
PRESIDENT BIDEN WAS SO FOCUSED
ON THE NEAR-TERM
NEAR-TERM CRISES, NOT THE
LONG TERM.
NO MENTION OF NORTH KOREA.
THE LIST GOES ON.
ON IRAN, MANY ADVERSARIES WERE
NOT MENTIONED MISSIONS ON THE
WORLD STAGE DID NOT MAKE IT IN.
>> Shannon: THAT SOMETHING THE
PRESIDENT HAS BEEN LAUDED FOR
FOR DECADES, THAT HE WAS THE
FOREIGN POLICY GUY.
YET ALL OF THE POLLING SHOWS US
NOW THAT AMERICANS INCREASINGLY
DO NOT TRUST HIM ON ISSUES OF
FOREIGN POLICY.
THEY WEREN'T GOOD THINGS FOR HIM
TO BRING UP LAST NIGHT.
I DON'T THINK HE WANTS TO
START -- IT'S A FULL PLATE.
HE AVOIDED THOSE, THERE WERE
CLUNKY THINGS.
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT ONE TOPIC,
AND ALL OF A SUDDEN -- ON TO
SOMETHING ELSE.
TOWARDS THE END, HE HAD THE
RHETORICAL STUFF WHERE HE STARTS
SOUNDING LIKE HE'S SCREAMING,
AND THE ENDING NOBODY COULD
FIGURE OUT.
IT WASN'T ONE OF HIS BEST
SPEECHES, BUT WITH THE POLLING
AGAINST HIM IN DOMESTICALLY AND
INTERNATIONALLY SO MANY FIRES
BURNING, I THINK HE JUST WANTED
TO GET IT DONE AND GET OUT.
>> Bret: ONCE THE VOTES, THE
OVER/UNDER HAD TO BE ABOUT
35/36.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Harris: THE OVER UNDER AND
FOLKS WHO HAD TO SHANNON'S
POINT, GOD BLESS THE TROOPS,
GOD BLESS AMERICA COME AND GO
GET 'EM.
>> Harris: IS THAT WHAT HE
SAID?
[LAUGHTER]
I WONDERED.
>> Kayleigh: WE WERE TALKING
ABOUT LAST NIGHT.
WHAT IS THAT REFERENCING?
>> Emily: WHO KNOWS THE MARKET
IN THAT THEY ANSWER TO EVERY
QUESTION, GETTING CLARITY?
BRETT MENTIONED THE LACKLUSTER
SHANNON MENTIONED THE SHOUTING.
SHOUTING IS NO SUBSTITUTE FOR
RESOLVE, DETERMINATION,
SERIOUSNESS.
THOSE WERE LACKING IN MY
OPINION, IN ADDITION TO CLARITY.
IT'S EXHAUSTING.
HE MOVED ON -- JUST GETTING TO
THE EXTRA MOVES WE WERE TALKING
ABOUT LAST NIGHT.
WE KEEP HEARING THEM.
MORE GENERALIZED, OVER SOME PLUS
TICK LIKE YOU ARE SAYING.
BEEN HEARING THEM SINCE HE WAS
CANDIDATE BIDEN.
HE'S NEVER FAILED TO SUPPORT ANY
TYPE OF POLICY OR ACHIEVEMENT.
WHEN HE DID REFERENCE THINGS, HE
FAILED --
>> Harris: INFRASTRUCTURE.
>> Emily: -- HE FAILED TO
TAKE RESPONSIBILITY WHEN HIS --
AND EXACERBATING OR CREATING THE
PROBLEMS.
WHEN HE TALKED ABOUT THE
CHILDREN'S RESPONSE ON
SOCIAL MEDIA, WHAT ABOUT THE
MENTAL HEALTH DECLINED FROM THE
PANDEMIC?
HE TALKED ABOUT APPOINTING A DOJ
PROSECUTOR.
HIS BUNGLING OF THE
DISSEMINATION OF THOSE FUNDS
CREATED THAT.
FINALLY, I THOUGHT ALSO SO
LITTLE
TOO WITHHOLD, TOO LATE.
THERE'S A LOT MORE, I HAD A LOT
OF ISSUES.
>> Harris: INFRASTRUCTURE, ONE
OF THE THINGS HE TOUTED.
THE SUPPLY CHAIN CRISIS
UNDERCUTS ANYTHING YOU WOULD
WANT TO DO ONE INFRASTRUCTURE IN
CERTAIN AREAS.
HE DIDN'T ADDRESS HOW IT WAS NOT
SANTA CLAUS WHO WAS GOING TO
BRING A RESOLUTION OF SUPPLY
CHAIN ISSUES WE HAVE.
NO CALL FOR MAKING IT UP IN THE
UNITED STATES.
HE HAD THE TIME.
HE COULD'VE MADE SOM